- I'm X.
- I'm Diane Warren.
- And this is the Academy Green Room.
(upbeat music)
Hey, X is back
and I'm here with the goat.
The goat of songwriting.
- Goat.
- The GOAT.
- There's a goat here?
- The Greatest Of All Time.
Yes, there is a GOAT in the building.
- I have a rescue ranch.
- Do you do?
- I have a farm animal rescue ranch.
And there's real goats there.
- Well...
- Those are the real goats.
- No, you're the real GOAT.
And then you also have goats.
You're the greatest when
it comes to songwriting.
- I know I'm not.
- But I'm claiming it on your behalf.
- Thank you, but I'm not.
- Diane, I have,
and see that's why you
that's what the greats do.
You're humble.
You're humble in your greatness.
And I'm gonna claim it for you.
- Okay.
- Now, normally when I do interviews,
I don't have access right now.
I would have an air horn on my intro.
And I'm gonna give you
a big intro right now.
'Cause we're on Spotify Live.
There's an audience
tapped in right now live,
we're in the Academy Green Room.
We're on Green Room.
13 Oscar nominations and counting.
- Yeah.
- You said something to me
right before we started.
You were like, that means I lost 12 times.
- Yeah, but I was nominated 12 times.
- That's what I'm saying.
- Actually nominated 13 times.
It's a big deal to be nominated.
- I think so too.
- Five songs are picked, only five songs.
Grammy's have how many song categories?
- That's right.
- Like endless,
and they have 40 song categories.
You know the Oscars have one, five songs.
- That's right.
- Think of all the songs released all year
and all the movies.
They only pick five.
If I'm one of those, that's winning.
- Let me, I'm gonna jump right in it.
How did writing for film
become a specialty of yours?
You clearly have a knack for it.
- I love doing it.
I mean, I just love writing songs
and it's fun to kind of
capture what a movie,
the heart of a movie.
- Yeah.
- That's what I like to do.
- What is your process?
- I process everything.
Yeah, okay.
My process, yeah,
in general writing is I show up
and do the work,
but for movies, I either read a script,
or preferably I see it.
I see a rough cut of it, which
like with four good days,
the one with somehow you do
that I'm nominated for this year.
- MacIntyre.
- MacIntyre will be singing it Sunday,
which I can't wait.
- Which is amazing.
- I hear it's gonna be amazing.
- I'm sure it is.
- Yeah.
- She's a legend.
- Yeah, she's great.
And she was perfect for this song
and perfect for this movie.
And when I do a song
for a movie I'm casting
the artist for the song,
that has to be authentic to the song
and authentic to the movie.
- Right.
- And she was both.
- How do you know when you nailed it?
Like you--
- I feel it.
It's just like, I'm
really a perfectionist.
And so when I'm satisfied
with something, I'm usually--
- How many hours would you say you spend
on one of those songs?
- Oh, I could spend a week on a song,
but lyrics are what I
take really time with,
that's the hard part, but
I'm really meticulous,
with lyrics
and music too,
but the music comes a little more easy,
but now then I gotta kind of
figure out what the story is,
then I got a really great chorus,
but how do I set that up?
I have a great first verse,
but then where do I go?
And then, okay.
I have a great second verse then
where do I do with that bridge?
How do I, how does that,
take it to the next level
it takes work.
- How much time do you spend with the film
before you even start writing?
Or you just start?
- I just see it or I read the script.
- Just once.
- Yeah.
- And then what are the conversations
like with the directors?
Because one thing about film
is the collaborative process.
- Usually they trust me.
Like again, I'll, with
this song, I had the chorus
and I played it for the director,
I had piece of verse too,
and he loved it.
So that was good.
- You have done so many--
- Better them when they hate it,
but that doesn't usually happen.
- I was about to say--
- I'm at the point where I play something,
I'm really excited about it.
I won't play for somebody
unless I love it.
- Tell me about a time where you loved it
and you were shocked
that they didn't love it
as much as you did
or did it happen?
- Well, there's a couple of,
but you know what, but
there's more that works out
than that don't to be honest.
- But how do you take it?
Because you've had so much success
and I think people can learn from it.
That's the reason I'm
pressing a little bit.
- Sometimes they don't
take a song for a movie
and then sometimes
something else happens with.
I remember writing something for,
I think it was "Sisterhood
of the Traveling Pants"
I wrote a really great song for it
and they didn't use it.
I was kind of like bummed out,
but right then Carrie
Underwood was doing an album
and she loved that song
and she did it.
And that album sold 12 million albums
and that worked out,
- It found another line.
- And if it was in that movie there,
I don't know who the artist was gonna be
or anything.
And so, you know what,
that they did me a favor.
- Already got a question
from the audience.
Diane is a legend
and has worked with so many iconic people.
It's gonna be a tough question for you,
who has been your favorite?
And they said, hi, Diane.
- Oh, hi, what's your name?
- Hi, whatever your name is.
- Let's get the name up.
- They're all my favorites.
Is that a great question?
- But I think that's favorite.
- I mean, a great answer?
A great, like, not get
myself in trouble answer?
- I would've answered the same way.
- Okay.
- Like, I mean, what are you gonna say?
- Yeah, if I say someone's my favorite
and I go wait, that's okay.
- But what about, what's your favorite,
I thought we really had something.
- Yeah, what's up with that, like, yeah.
I'm not gonna work with you again,
cause I'm not your favorite.
- I mean, it's so much I can ask you.
I mean, so many songs,
like nine number one songs
on the Billboard,
32 top 10 songs on a Billboard Hot 100,
including "If I could
turn back time", "Share".
I wanna know some of the
stories of these songs.
And does it ever get to a
point where you make a song
that's so big that you get tired of it?
- No, I don't get tired of it.
'Cause if I'm getting tired
of it, that's a good thing.
I mean, if I'm like, if it's
getting it's a play too much.
- It's like a good problem.
- That's what I mean, yeah.
- It's like, I don't, know,
I'm grateful for any success
or if people know my songs.
- Yeah.
- Or like right now on TikTok,
I wrote a song for Paloma Faith.
That was a number one record,
like outside of America, everywhere else.
'Cause she, no one knows who she is here.
Now all of a sudden on TikTok,
it has like 350,000
videos in the last month
or something.
So it's like, wow,
that's a whole other world
that I've never been a part of.
So that just gave a whole
other life to that song.
- How do you keep it fresh?
Like how do you get inspired.
- I work every day.
I get inspired every day
I come up with ideas,
I just, I work.
- Well, what's the--
- It's like an Olympic athlete.
If you wanna be in the
Olympics, you better practice.
And you have to practice every day
and you have to work
and you have to put in the time
and you have to put in the work.
- Get a rep set.
- It's that simple.
- Do you study other artists?
Are there any other artists?
- No.
- That you just--
- I don't study artists,
but I of course been influenced by stuff.
- Yeah, I wanna go back then,
'cause I'm sitting now with a legend.
I really mean that.
I know you don't like that.
You're a legend Diane.
- Makes me feel old.
- Well, it's not about that.
It's just about your accomplishments.
You've been a legend for some time just
because you've had some
amazing accomplishments.
- I'm still here.
I'm still in the game.
- That's right.
You're still acting.
- I'm still kicking ass.
- That's right.
- Yeah.
That's the kind of, what's awesome.
Like if I had a choice,
like back to the Oscars,
if I had a choice of winning
and being one of these nominations.
- Yeah.
- And never being nominated
again, I would choose to,
the longevity of 34 years
and 13 nominations.
- Can we go back to when
you first wrote for a movie,
what was that story?
How did that come about?
- That was my first big hit
really was "Rhythm of the Night"
- What a great--
- DeBarge.
- What a great song.
- Thank you.
- I love that song.
So yeah,
and it was what was
really awesome for me is
I'm such a Motown fan
and growing up,
I just loved all every artist
on Motown, all the songs.
So for my first big hit to
be on Motown with Barry Gordy
it's a coolest thing ever, yeah.
- And then from there,
was it just kind of like,
then you got the next one,
like somebody heard that, liked it
and then offered you the next one.
- You're talking about movies.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I just kind of kept doing it.
Like, I just think it's something,
that my dad put so as
long as I went to college,
he'd support me.
And so I took all these
real like movie classes,
so I didn't have to do anything.
So it was basically a college rabbi.
So I took a lot of like film history.
- Yeah.
- Watched old movies and stuff like that.
But I think in doing that I almost maybe,
- Something.
- Yeah, exactly.
- That you just translate
because you really it's
really storytelling.
Like you mentioned like
you're trying to figure out
what the story is,
how it ties into the yeah.
What the part is, how
it ties into the bridge.
- Yeah.
- And come to completion.
It's almost like a story within a story.
- Yeah, it really is.
Wow.
- And your story is really complimentary
to what you felt
and saw on a screen.
- That story inspired that story
and then the stories work together.
- Yeah, then they build--
- Create something else.
Yeah, to create something all new.
Tiffany asks, what is your best advice
for women songwriters want wanting
to break into the industry?
- I mean, for any songwriter,
to break into the industry,
whether you're a woman or a man,
you gotta put in the time.
- Yeah.
- You have to have talent, A,
'cause if you don't have talent,
then all the time
and work won't it's aptitude and attitude
and gratitude.
If that makes sense.
- No, it makes total sense.
Okay, we got another one.
The questions are flooded
in this one is from Henry.
Has TikTok changed the way
you think about songwriting?
- No, 'cause it all comes down to my job
is to make the best
song I can make, right?
So TikTok does,
I'm not gonna write a song
that lasts for 10 seconds
or whatever.
- Right.
- I do wanna have a full song.
I mean, it's just another way
people are gonna hear songs.
Like with "Only Love Can Hurt Like This".
- Yeah.
- Which is the one that
is like this huge viral
TikTok thing right now.
But it's so interesting to
watch all these videos of,
some of them like make you cry.
Like some are very emotional.
- Right.
- If you get a chance to look.
- I'm definitely gonna do that.
- And then go listen to the whole song.
It's a great song,
but what people have done with it,
these stories, these
little miniature stories
they tell with my songs,
that's new to me,
but to answer the question, no,
I still wanna write the songs.
I write great songs.
- No.
- Then you guys can make 15 minute videos,
15 second video.
- Which is incredible.
- Which is cool.
We talked about the collaboration process
between filmmakers,
how you look at that.
But a lot of your songwriting,
I mean your songwriting,
you do by yourself.
- Yeah, all my, yeah.
It was just in the studio
with Rita Ora yesterday.
- Yeah.
- And I just did a great song with her.
So she was holding up my lyric sheet
and going, "Look, one name, guys."
Like that's weird.
- It is weird.
- No, I know in this day and age,
when there's 10 to 15 songs,
minimum of five writers on a song,
I'm a unicorn, yeah.
- That's right.
- So it's a trip.
- I was looking at album credits.
I'll let the art us remain nameless.
'Cause I always look at the credits.
I always do that.
I wanna see who wrote it, who produced it?
Who engineered it.
- It's hard to find now, right?
- It's so hard to find.
- That's what I miss about
actually buying records
where you can see on the record.
- You hold it.
- Now you have to go, okay.
what do I go to All Music?
Do I go do--
- Oh yeah.
- Can I say that on?
- Yeah.
- All right, I'm going, like,
where do you go to line?
The credits like,
'cause I like to know
who wrote various stuff.
- And it's like, I clicked on one.
- Sherlock Holmes to find.
- I'll show you how to do it on Spotify.
It's not as hard as the other ones,
but it's a little trick to it.
But it was one
and one song I'm not exaggerating
had 15 songwriters on it.
- Yeah, what was it?
The Mark Ronson, Bruno Morrison.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Uptown funk.
- Yeah, uptown funk.
- That kept growing writers every week.
So I think there's a lot of songs.
A lot of samples.
Yeah, then they had finding.
- More writers now.
- Right, what is your
approach to sampling?
- I don't sample.
- Never have.
- No, I mean, I just write songs,
I don't sample other songs.
- And how do you.
- And I hope that when
someone does records of them,
I'm always really careful with that.
Please don't have that be a sample.
- Right.
Oh yeah.
- When doing records, you're like listen.
- Don't do that
or I'm gonna have I,
all my song's gonna grow 10 writers on it.
- And you can't have that.
- So no, I'm not into that.
- How do you write across
so many genres right now?
The Reba MacIntyre song?
That's country.
- Yes, country.
- Aerosmith.
You did El DeBarge.
- Yeah, I'm all over the place.
I do like classical crossover stuff
and I do a lot of R&B stuff.
- Yeah.
- Even I just did my first record,
my features record where
I'm kind of like a DJ.
- Yeah.
- And I have everybody on there from like,
Maren Morris to TY Dolla $ign
to John Batiste
and Pentatonix, to Celine
Dion to John legend.
So it's kind of all over the place.
- And how did you pick
the artist that you wanted
to collab with?
- I just had songs I
wanted to put on there.
I had too many songs, so
I'm gonna do a Volume II.
- Nice.
- And I have more now that I wanna do too.
- When is it coming?
- Well, I have a few that
didn't get on that one.
'Cause I kept writing new songs.
Like I met John Batiste.
Well I knew John Batiste,
but I saw him at last year's Oscars.
- Yeah.
- And I'd just written my songs "Sweet".
And I met Pentonix through my dentist.
(X chuckles)
Which is so random and weird.
Oh, it's funny.
I just realized Sweet and Dennis,
that's why you go to a dentist.
- Exactly.
- You have a cavity.
- Too many sweets.
- Wow!
Okay, that's interesting
and random.
And so I ran into to John, he won
and I lost for my 12th time.
Last year's Oscars.
- Oh, well I wasn't gonna bring that up.
- It's okay.
And I told him about the song
and he loved it
and had stopped my record
and took something else off.
And you know, I'm excited about that song.
We're gonna be doing the video soon.
I love that song.
- So this is gonna be the
lead single off Volume II
- Yeah, it's gonna come out.
Well, not the lead.
No, it's still on Volume I.
- Oh, it's still on Volume I.
So it's just continue to push the product.
- But I love it.
I think it's such an upbeat
and happy song.
It just makes you, it
kind of fits just summer.
- When you're not writing for film
or you're not writing.
- I'm always writing, yeah.
- That's what I was gonna ask.
- You just constantly writing.
- I was in the I was, I
just came from the office.
I was working on a really cool song today.
- Can you tell me anything about the song?
- No, it's a secret.
- Why is it?
- I don't want--
- You got so many.
- No, it's really good though.
- I bet it is.
- I like that was kind of happy,
I was excited about it.
- I love it.
Just let me know when
I can hear, let me know
- I will just stay in touch.
- Please, I would absolutely love that.
- All right.
- Another question,
this one is from Marcus.
I like this question a lot.
Do you have any songs you
love that you wish you wrote?
- Okay, I'm gonna answer this
the way I've always answered
this question.
No, because I wasn't meant to write them.
- That's real.
- Yeah, it's from my heart.
That's real.
The songs I love, but
those weren't my songs.
- Yeah.
- Those weren't meant--
- Like I got--
- Yeah, I'm cool.
I got some good songs,
I meant to write the ones I write,
but yeah, I'm happy, is
Steven Tyler, one of your--
- Your favorite artist.
- Yeah, Steven Tyler's awesome.
- I mean.
- Like you know what a voice,
what he's like a true rock star,
and he's a great guy.
That's one of my favorites by you.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- I was still, I was
shocked when they decided
to do my song.
They never did a songwriter song.
I mean, a Beatles song doesn't count.
- Right.
- That's the Beatles.
- And speaking of that,
I had Paul McCartney
and Ringo Star on the
song of mine last year.
It was Ringo Star, song's
called "Here's to the Nights"
Yeah.
He asked me for a song
and first of all, I'm
the biggest Beatles fan.
And I'd done a song for Ringo before,
but I thought, okay, I had a
whole concept with this song,
so let's get your old friends
and then let's get some new friends.
- Okay.
- And my old friends,
my little idea was to get Paul McCartney.
And so he loved the idea
and he got Paul,
Paul was the first one to sign on.
And then we got like Chris Stapleton.
Amazing songwriter himself.
- Yeah.
- By the way he's amazing.
- FINNEAS is on there.
Lenny Kravitz is on there.
- Yeah.
- Dave Grol's on there.
It's pretty cool.
But like, all I saw was, Ringo star
and Paul McCartney in my mind.
- I mean, the fact that you like.
- In the video, there's a video
and they're singing it together.
- I haven't seen it.
I gotta admit.
- Watch it, it's really good.
- I'm watching that the second--
- That pinch me thing to this day.
- I was gonna ask you
about pinch me moments.
- That's a pinch me moment.
- That's one give, give me a couple more.
- I mean, like it doesn't
get better than that.
- I mean, Paul McCartney
and Ringo Star on your song.
- I mean, they're all pinch me moments,
look getting nominated this
year was a pinch me moment.
- Right.
- 'Cause I was not a shoe in,
there was a lot of,
this was the most
competitive year I ever saw.
- I totally agree.
- And so I like just
stayed up all night waiting
and my song was the last one called
and I had 10 heart attacks before that.
But you know what?
It was just the most wonderful moment.
So that was like, yeah.
- Is that what you normally do?
Do you normally stay, wait,
- Yeah.
- Stay up all night.
- Yeah, I'm not cool
enough to go to sleep.
Like all these other
people go yeah, my age
and my manager.
Oh yeah.
- Nah, yeah.
You're like--
- You just think you're really cool
and don't wanna admit it
and I'm not cool and I don't give it,
so I stay up all night
and admit it and I'm happy to admit it.
- And then when you hear your
name called, what's that like.
- It wasn't not my name.
It was the name of the song.
And I was just like,
I just was in shock 'cause
really this was lot,
this was a smaller movie.
- It is.
- And I mean, Drew McIntyre's a superstar,
but there were a lot of, there was like,
there's billion dollar
movies out there with you too
and Jennifer Hudson
and a lot of other stars.
- Oh yeah, the Aretha movie.
- Yeah.
- There's a lot of like, it's like,
a lot of prognosticators,
most of them did not see
my song in the top five.
I'm like, yeah.
- Right.
- Yeah, see.
Yeah, you're like see, right?
- I love to prove people wrong.
- You should tell me
about a time then where...
- That I proved people wrong.
- All the time.
Proving people wrong.
- What are they saying about you?
What are they saying to you?
- Oh, I don't know.
Whenever someone says like,
you can't do something.
I love it, 'cause then I do it.
- Yeah, you're like, I'm--
- Soon as they say I can't
do it, I'm gonna do it.
- You go right at it.
- Yeah.
- If you don't want me to do something,
tell me I can't do it.
(Diane chuckles)
- All right.
I'm gonna think of one before
this interview is over.
Who's an artist you
haven't worked with yet
and you're like one day if possible.
- Sorry, there's not one
artist to be totally honest.
- I take any names you can give.
- But there's people like
the artist I'm supposed work
with find me
or I find them somehow.
- Yeah.
- So it's not like, well,
if I only work with,
it's gonna happen.
I work with really great artists.
I'm very blessed that way.
- You've been very blessed like that.
- Yeah, so.
- Because you work so often,
are there artists that
have reached out to you.
Please don't feel like
you gotta name any names.
'Cause that's not what I'm asking for,
but what you just say,
no, I don't think this is a good match
because I can only imagine
that people reach out to you.
- Yeah, sure.
- And what do you base
that on when you say no?
- I mean honestly like someone
has to have something going
it's hard to work with
somebody that, starting out.
'Cause it it's so much work, right?
And so I'd like someone,
they have to be a great singer
or someone that I think I can help
and that I can fit into their thing.
- Yeah.
- Or has something going on
just being totally honest.
- No, but that's so hard.
- It's so hard.
- I find it refreshing
that you actually say that
because on the flip side though,
because they could use you
almost the like prop themselves.
- Or sometimes though, if
it depends on the artist,
it's always artist by artist.
I might hear somebody that I love so much
that I'm willing to take that chance.
- And you just like, love it.
Let's let's do this.
Let's make it happen.
- Exactly.
- I'm gonna ask you just,
what was the first album you ever bought?
- It was a Beatles album.
"Meet the Beatles".
- And what was it about them at that time?
- I just, I was a kid.
I have older sisters just,
I love them.
I got to grow up in a time
of really great music.
- Yeah.
- So as a songwriter,
I've always been a sponge
with all kinds of influences.
That's why I can write
in all these genres.
- What are some of those influencers,
you mentioned Motown.
You mentioned the Beatles.
- Yeah, I got everything.
I mean every Motown artist,
just soul in general,
I don't know so much stuff.
- Just a lot of inspirations.
- Yeah.
'Cause when I grew up the
radio played everything.
- That's true.
What are you listening to these days?
- I listen to things honestly,
to hear artists I'm working with.
And to hear what's going on.
'Cause I have to cause I'm
working with a lot of artists.
- Right.
- But I don't like in the daytime,
I'm doing my own music.
And when I go home,
I don't usually listen to music
'cause my ears need to rest
and I'm gonna go back the next day.
- So what are you do when
you're not listening to music?
'Cause we get inspirations from everyone.
- I listen to people's conversations.
I like to go to restaurants
and listen up to people.
I read, I watch movies, see friends,
ideas are everywhere.
You just have to be open to them.
- Open to receiving them.
- Yeah.
- What haven't you written about yet
that you wanna write about?
What's the story you want to tell?
- Oh, I don't know.
- You haven't told about in--
- I'm not sure what that is.
I'll let you know.
And then I'll when I
write it, I'll go see.
- I you'll be like, that's
one I hadn't done yet.
Got another one we wanna
take from the audience.
This is from Ibraheem.
How did the idea of the
Cave Session come up
and working with different artists?
- Well I was checking out like.
- If you talk about,
can you say what the Cave
Session is for those?
- Yeah, so the cave sessions
is me being DJ Diane.
It's what, Mark Ronson
or DJ Khaled
or Calvin Harris does where
they're kind of curating songs
and artists, right?
I thought, you know what, I
wanna do the songwriter version
of that.
And I write in so many genres,
you've heard different artists
that I could pull that off,
And it kind of started
'cause I have a song that
John Legend I did called
"Where Is Your Heart?"
- Yeah.
- It's on my record.
I wish I had singles rights,
'cause it's such a hit.
- Yeah.
- Come on, John.
Gimme singles rights.
- Yeah, come on John.
- Come on.
- Let's just make that happen.
- And he recorded the song.
He kept saying he was gonna use it.
He didn't use it.
I gave it to an artist
and then he said he wanted it back
and I piss off an artist
and then he didn't use it.
- So how'd that go?
- Wait, so, then he didn't use it again.
I gave it to another artist.
Then he wanted it back again
and then he didn't use it
and I go, I believe in this song so much
with your voice.
Like it's just one of the
best things I've ever heard.
If you get a chance to
listen to the album.
- Yeah.
- Listen to, where is your heart?
John legend.
And I finally, I go, you know what,
and that kind of,
when I did came up with the
idea of doing my DJ Diane kind
of thing, I thought,
okay, I'm putting words,
where is your heart on here.
It needs to be heard.
- This is from Lauren.
What's up Lauren.
- What songs do you.
- What songs do you have on repeat?
- I mean, nothing really?
I mean, I'm just I'm well, okay.
To be honest, when I'm writing,
I'm repeating all day long,
I'm playing over and over.
So I'm kind of my stuff's on repeat,
but it's like when I was a kid,
my dad got a shed in the backyard.
My parents couldn't listen
to me playing my songs over.
- Oh, they put you in a shed.
- Yeah, they did.
They go, it's like, okay,
work on those songs outside in the winter,
there'd be a little heater there.
So yeah.
That's what I'm, that's what's on repeat.
I'm always just trying to
figure stuff out as I'm doing.
- And you just know it when you feel it.
- Yeah.
And then you go on to the
next part of you're like,
okay, I got that figured out.
- Yep.
- Onto the next piece.
And then you just piece
it together bit by bit.
- Yeah.
- I love that approach to it.
- It's being a craftsman.
It's funny, I was with some of
my music friends last night,
we were talking about that
you could be an artist
or a craftsman
and I go, no.
- Talk about the difference.
What's the difference?
- No, you're both
because you can't be one.
You can't be a great artist
without being a great craftsman.
- Right.
- And care about craftsmanship.
- Yeah, because it's a craft.
So yeah, that was it's interesting.
When we were talking a
conversation last night.
- Do you see any changes
besides the million
and one songwriters on every song?
- Songwriting by committee?
- Yeah, like, do you see--
- I hate committees.
- I was gonna, essentially
that's (indistinct)
committees that's.
- I came up with that word.
- That's good.
- Not that the songwriters are committees,
but just committees in
general are committees.
- And talk to me about
what you don't like about
that process.
It's about the passion of
one person, not a committee.
The committee is, what do you think?
What do you think?
What do you, so what do you.
No, it's what do you feel?
And what is one person?
That's how things get done.
It's by passion.
- I think that also takes a
certain amount of confidence.
- Yeah.
- In what you're, what
you're putting down.
- I haven't had a problem with
self confidence in my work.
- You just always had it.
You just--
- Yeah, even when I didn't
have any reason to believe
in myself, I did, but that's
but you have to have it
because everything's against you.
- And yeah, and it's a no business.
I tell people like it's
designed to weed you out.
- Yeah, exactly.
If you can't handle
that, you don't belong.
- This is not the business for you.
- It's like the Marines.
- That's right.
- I mean, it is.
- It's designed to weed you out.
It's designed to break you down.
I can tell that's why really
behind why you keep working.
'Cause you're like, if I'm not
working and what am I doing?
- Yeah.
I wouldn't know what to do.
- Right.
- Like, I want me sit on a beach.
I can't and do that for an
hour 'cause I get so bored.
You're like what am I actually doing?
- Okay, let's go shopping or something.
- Right, you like need to be engaged.
- I have to be, yeah I do.
- What do you define as work life balance?
- I don't know.
- If it exists.
- I wouldn't know.
I don't have the most
balanced life to be honest,
but I love my work.
So that's living for me.
- Right.
Just living in the world.
- Yeah, that's life to me.
- Right, lemme take one more
question from the audience.
Before I close out the legend.
This from Jazz.
Great name.
How do you start your day?
Meditation, breakfast, morning walk.
- No, I have like an ice blended mocha.
You go have coffee and go to work.
- You stop for lunch, right?
- Oh yeah.
- Okay, you actually take
an actual lunch break.
- Yeah.
- Reset.
- And then I might have a meeting
and things like that, but
no, I start like coffee
is important.
- So your songwriting process,
sometimes I can take a leak.
- That's my process.
- You just show up and do it.
- I show up and I work.
- Do you ever like not finish any
or it sounds like you
just finish them all.
I try to finish stuff,
but I have little starts
that I'll go back to.
- And when do you know
to come back to them?
- They tell me, they call me.
You just hear them and you're like, okay.
- Yeah.
- I got it.
So I mentioned, I mentioned
before we started Dixon,
the producer
and co-writer of Beyonce's Be Alive,
that's also nominated called you a legend.
He asked who I was talking to next.
- No legend just makes me sound like old.
And so I'm just,
I feel like I've just starting.
- That's but that's great.
But we just wanted to
shout you out though.
He wanted me to tell you that
'cause he was sitting in that same spot
and he got a little starstruck
that I was gonna speak to you.
- Really?
- Yes.
- Oh my God.
- I'm telling you no reason to.
- Only because I don't get starstruck,
but I've been following your career.
I've been seeing your name in those lines.
- When you can find yeah.
- You know what I mean, right?
And I gotta show you how
to find it on Spotify,
but I've been seeing your name
and liners for years on so many songs.
- Like I've been around that.
- That I love in so
many movies that I love
and thank you for doing what you do.
- Thank you.
- Like seriously, you're an inspiration.
- And thank you for
taking time to talk to me.
- My cat.
- DJ cat.
- Look at her,
can we get a close up on her shirt?
DJ cat, literally.
That's what my cat spike looks like.
I showed her a picture.
- You gotta see my cat too.
When you go on Instagram, Rabbit.
She has really big
theirs, that's why she's--
- Diane Warren wishing you the best.
God bless you.
I'm gonna keep supporting you.
And I see you on Sunday.
- Yes, I'll see you.
Can't wait.
- Cheers.
(upbeat music)